it is maddening to be reminded to
appreciate what we have for someone to
tell us we shouldn't forget to be
grateful it's in conflict with our times
and their emphasis on constant ambition
and striving
the idea of pausing to take stock of
what has gone well to be content with
many things as they are this feels
strange and dangerous like some kind of
losers cancel or the consolation prize
but in truth there is so much that if we
learned we might be dead by nightfall we
will promptly remember to value the
summer night sky the taste of cold milk
old brick walls deserted railway
stations the presence of our partners
beside us in the stillness of dawn we
are ungrateful partly out of a fear a
fear of accepting what we have as if to
pause to appreciate things as they are
might make a soft complacent without the
willpower to take on new challenges
anxiety feels so much more natural it's
been with us from the start
but ultimately it's not heroic or
sensible always to be dissatisfied
relentlessly to focus on everything
that's gone wrong and to obsess about
our humiliations and rejections there
isn't truth far more courage and skill
in being able to identify a hopeful
perspective in knowing how to train and
keep our eyes on what's being more or
less okay what can best help us in this
oddly is the thought of our own death
how soon and how unexpectedly it may
come and how much we'll miss about life
when it does we are constantly
undermined by our failure to retain the
purity and drama of this helpfully
morbid insight which would strike us
once every day at least and to put it to
powerful use in the ordinary course of
life gratitude is the dividend due to us
one for a few moments we begin to assess
our lives with a truer sense of all our
small but significant advantages and
with a frank humble recognition of all
we have to lose and one day will
you